we are so good at telling everybody
what's wrong with everybody else besides
ourselves the sheer lack of
accountability in the human race today
is staggering there is nothing more
obvious to me than that happiness starts
with accountability it is the most
liberating truth of all time of course
I'm logically understanding that there's
other people that there's other
variables but I'm completely in control
to what I do here's my favorite one
about people that employ people they sit
around and complain about their
employees 20 247 and they're in control
of firing
them fire
them by the way you know what was the
best part of that line none of the
bosses wanted to clap we love to point
fingers we hate a thumb